the state of California coming out of
their state Senate and Assembly a bill
that has headed to the desk of
California governor Gavin Newsom that
would allow student athletes in the
state of California through the fair pay
to play act to make money off of their
likeness a business model for major
college sports potentially that the NCAA
isn't too happy about that they would
receiving compensation for everything
from their likeness to being able to
make a little bit of money off of what
they went ahead and are doing collegiate
ly on a court or in a pool or on a field
so to talk about all of this is our
conscience when it comes to collegiate
athletics we love this man one of our
favorite guests from ESPN Jay Bilas how
are you Jay I'm doing great rich how are
you did I get that right with the fair
pay to play act in the state of
California best you know yes yes it's
basically name image and likeness rights
so the players off the floor or off the
field as you say would be able to make
make money off their name image and
likeness now there has been an amendment
to that legislation which which
basically says that the players would
not be able to monetize things that
would be in conflict with with school
deals and so my my guest there is that
if you know if Duke has a deal with with
Nike that Zion Williamson couldn't just
go out sign a deal with Under Armour or
something and wear a different shoe even
though that happens in the NBA did Major
League Baseball the NFL and it's it's
easily remedied it would be things that
would not be in conflict with with
school deals okay so let's just say
somebody who is particularly famous
because of what they do
athletically at the collegiate level
just wants to have a signing deal where
they sign stuff for the day or they want
to make a commercial for for something
that does not conflict with what the
school is already doing what's wrong
with that
yeah there's nothing wrong with it and
in fact rich I have believed for a long
time that this is a civil rights issue
and you know players in college don't
have the same economic rights as their
fellow students any student that is a
non athlete is allowed to earn or accept
whatever they choose in the marketplace
and in fact they're celebrated at their
their college and university for for
doing so you know give you an example my
daughter just graduated college a couple
years ago she's a very talented artist
we're very proud of her but she was
majoring in art she sold her artwork
while she was in school and made made
good money doing it
you know that's celebrated and
considered to be a good thing but if you
know if an athlete were to sell an
autograph or do something out in the
commercial space they'd be ineligible
and and frankly they'd be treated a
little bit like a criminal you know
you've seen Ohio State years ago guys
sold jerseys and that became a huge
issue so it's things like that that
would be opened up and and it wouldn't
wouldn't be you know the instantly wants
to make it seem like it would create all
these complications that wouldn't create
any complications and one of the
laughable things I've heard recently is
well what if you know what if an athlete
wanted to do a an ad for a casino or for
a cannabis company or something like
that and we couldn't have that well what
if Nick Saban wanted to do that or what
if Mike chefs you wanted to do that you
know the the the universities can handle
those issues just fine they don't need a
blanket rule that says nobody can have
anything because because we're worried
about the you know sort of the crazy
doomsday example well it's not just the
NCAA to Jay Bilas in this New York Times
article that I'm reading about it the
athletic director at Long Beach State
and effets is quoted as saying it's like
you and I sit down to play Monopoly and
I pull out a different rule book and
every time I pass go I'm gonna get
myself $400 instead of $200 and his
point there being that if California
does this in the rest of the member
states of the NCAA and the United States
don't allow this to happen in their
states then California has that
advantage and thus I don't imagine quote
too many people are going to be willing
to allow California schools to compete
for NCAA Championships because they
might get better athletes to come to
California because California allows
them to make money off their name and
likeness what do you say to that well I
count the Long Beach State athletic
director as the n-c-double-a so the
internet ablaze always you know falling
all over themselves to say that the
n-c-double-a is the member school so
that's the n-c-double-a perspective that
I'm talking about and it's sort of more
of the same rich I mean you know with
all due respect athletic directors
around the country and commissioners
that use the same party line you know
their way to take that ridiculous
monopoly analogy they're not worried
about differences in spending in any
other area except for athletes so so the
Long Beach State athletic director is
not worried about passing go when
building a six hundred million dollar
facility at Alabama or worried about you
know the coaches making ten million
dollars at other schools when when Long
Beach State can only afford to pay seven
hundred thousand dollars to their their
you know their basketball coach or
whether they have a football program and
somebody else doesn't or whether
university has a hospital and somebody
else does it you know it's all this sort
of situational ethics and and they're
drawing the line in one place only
there's no spending control on college
athletics there's only one and that's
the athlete and and what they're really
saying is the athletes the most valuable
commodity here and and if we're allowed
to pay then then the best athletes may
go where the money is and that means and
really what they're doing you know this
rich I mean a preach of the choir here
but you know all the best athletes are
going to the power five schools anyway I
mean that's demonstrated and and and
without that's without argument so that
doesn't mean the Long Beach State can't
win once in a while but but I think you
can see from from the results that you
don't see Long Beach State you know at
the top of the rankings and in the the
money sports now whether they do well in
volleyball great but but that's not what
we're arguing about here and what we're
arguing about is there's no reason that
a volleyball player at Long Beach State
shouldn't be able to
capitalise on his or her name image and
likeness or swimmers like Missy Franklin
why shouldn't Missy Franklin a cat when
she was a cow be able to monetize her
name image like this what would that
have to do with any swimming result it
wouldn't and and we need to sort of let
go of this antiquated thinking and these
really the truth is nonsensical excuses
we've been making for all this time
College GameDay as well as play analyst
table for games all around college
analysts ESPN's Jay Bilas here on the
Rich Eisen show so Mark Emmert
of the NCAA is saying to the state of
California give us some time for our
Commission that has been convened for
this sort of subject before before you
send the bill to the governor's desk the
assembly is basically and the Senate is
told the n-c-double-a to pounce and what
do you see as the next few steps here in
all this Jay well they are getting some
time rich because the the legislation is
not going to go into effect if governor
Newsome signs until 2023 so the answer
ladies got plenty of time and you know I
would argue they've had since 1906 to
figure this out and they've shown a
tremendous amount of inertia and they've
not done anything they don't want to and
so it isn't just the state of California
that's doing this Congress is involved
you know Senator Chris Murphy of
Connecticut and representative art
Walker of North Carolina are both
pushing the same thing through Congress
so you know that there's you know it's
one thing to have you know gas bags like
me talking about this over the years but
it's another thing when the government's
involved so the unstably is being pushed
and and right you know they've been
lawsuits forever and and incidentally
starting to lose some of these antitrust
cases they've been losing them
consistently they haven't lost every
aspect of them but that's that part of
it I think is coming in time and I
thought it was interesting the Mark
Emmert response was to send a letter to
the state of California basically saying
if this train continues going down the
tracks the way we're going to respond to
it is we're going to tie the players to
the tracks and you're just going to run
the players over basically saying you
know you're going to hurt the players
and we're going to punish
the players for this I found that to be
a pretty distasteful response in
California basically respond advice i
think was a nancy skinner basically said
you know you think you're gonna threaten
us you're wrong and and the recent vote
was seventy two to nothing so clearly
Mark Emmert and his people miscalculated
the resolve of the state of California
but also the idea that the n-c-double-a
is just going to say well that's it
California can't compete anymore that
that's laughable that's not going to
happen it's going to require an
adjustment of the part of the
n-c-double-a and they're going to adjust
and and you know this is not this big of
a deal and look I get it like if I look
if I could keep all the money I'd want
to keep it as long as possible - but the
writing's on the wall and this is
inevitable that this is going to happen
it's kind of like with the Olympics
where everybody said boy you let pros in
the Olympics and that's the end of the
Olympics and they're more popular than
ever
you know the Olympics that just haven't
pros in the Olympics and you know
allowing allowing the Olympic athletes
to monetize their name image and
likeness has certainly not spelled
doomsday for the Olympics and it won't
for college sports either just like just
like paying coaches eight nine ten
million dollars a year hasn't been the
death knell for for college sports
players being able to monetize their you
know their name image and likeness won't
won't be a problem either well I guess
their concern is Jay Bilas of ESPN here
their concern is and Larry Scott of the
pac-12 has said it here that anything
that there were firmly against anything
that would lead to a pay for play system
because again it does make zero sense to
not allow their name and likeness to be
monetized it's their name it's their
likeness let's roll I don't see how the
the shoe contracts writ large for each
school or whatever soft drink contracts
or whatever contracts there are for
television are going to be less money
because the handful because I it's not
gonna be everybody
I mean whoever has a market they should
be able to take advantage of it how does
this so however lead to what they're
saying pay for play system how walk me
through that logic Jay well what what I
think what they're concerned about and
where this may may lead is the idea that
you do have players say they say we have
an open system where players can
monetize their name evident likeness the
schools are going to find that difficult
to deal with so what they what they may
wind up doing is saying look it's so
much easier for us to just pay the
players and then be able to control what
they do rather than have the system
where you know we may have a contract
with McDonald's and another kid is doing
a deal with Burger King or you know that
they just like with the coaches you know
the coaches can't go out and endorse
whatever products they want to they have
to get approval from the University and
the reasons they they have that a
university has that approval is because
the coach signs a contract and and they
pay for that that right to be able to
tell them that they can't make make
money outside their contract so the the
easiest thing to do for the schools is
just sign players to contracts and and
you know I look I get that I just
strikes me as really odd that Larry
Scott his brethren
you know Bob Bowles B says this all the
time and it look they're both great guys
but I just don't agree with this stuff
you know Bob Bowles me the Commissioner
of the big 12 says constantly if we ever
pay the players we will have forever
lost our way in college sports and like
why is that the issue instead of like
you know you don't hear any of these
guys saying look if we ever start
playing nine o'clock games on weekdays
we will forever have lost our way or if
we ever start selling these players for
billions of dollars we will have forever
lost our way if we ever start paying
coaches ten million that we will forever
have lost our way if we if we're going
to lose our way over the players we lost
our way a long time ago and if these
players are old enough to sell they are
old enough to make money and especially
when every other student is allowed to
do it like we don't have these rules in
place for you know the journalism
student on scholarship that they can go
out and write a book or the music
student on scholarship they can go out
and cut a record or you know play in a
play in a band and make money while
they're in school we celebrate those as
like these these money earning
entrepreneurs but an athlete boy we got
to keep that contagion in or
everything's going to be lost and dogs
and cats are going to be living together
and will be chaos
and it's just not true
I mean it's just not true well the last
one for you on this I got two more
questions for you Jay Bilas last one on
this is your you don't play one on TV
but you are a lawyer and you're an
expert at the the I guess bureaucracy of
the NCAA you say they're gonna have to
adjust and right now their adjustment as
you've pointed out is to basically say
California if you do this it would be
such a disadvantage for the rest of the
schools the member schools in the 49
other states that you would obviously
get more kids and better kids and better
athletes to come there because of what
you're offering them to do with their
name and likeness and image we're just
not gonna let you play and as you point
out that is absurd that they won't be
able to compete for titles from the
state of California what do you think
their adjustment is going to be or will
they just sue the heck out of California
and try and delay it here
no California sue the heck out of the
infidel blaze what will happen and but
that's all the incidentally needs or
more lawsuits because they pay an
extraordinary amount in in legal fees in
order to keep this system intact and
it's almost like the old line from you
know Butch Cassidy the Sundance Kid when
you know Paul Newman says you know if
they if they just give us what it's
costing them you know for us to stop
robbing them we'd stop robbing us you
know that kind of thing right if they're
spending so much money on legal fees
you're like what why don't you just want
you just look the players you have the
money it's not that big of a deal but
they're not going to do what they say
that they're just threatening that and
with all the money they spend on
lobbying in Washington DC eight other
states and and what they're paying in
legal fees it's a total waste of money
when one we're in processes pro sports
and most people not everybody but most
most reasonable people see this for what
it is they see it as a control thing
that the instantly wants to control
everything and control all the money but
I'm not saying I blame them no I
understand you're saying that Jay but
when it all comes down to it that if
2023 hits and the NCAA has not done a
single adjustment for the other 49
states it really would be a competitive
advantage for
all the schools in the state of
California I mean you there's no denying
that if there's only one state that has
and I understand that there's a federal
law out there and there are other states
that are gonna get in on this maybe but
don't you think there that is a
competitive disadvantage for everybody
else right J yeah and all they have to
do is pass the same legislation in their
own state they're there they're just
fine I mean it's really simple
and well what this is going to do is
just a catalyst that's gonna that's
going to force the n-c-double-a to do
something and that's basically what this
legislation is designed to do is that
that I think California and and and the
truth is United States Congress I mean
I've spoken with with numerous different
you know senators and representatives
who call for information and you know
I'll talk about this all the time
talking about on your show I'll talk to
anybody about it so I can ask me
whatever they want but you know the
people see this as fundamentally unfair
and they've listened to the n-c-double-a
over the years say well we're looking at
it well they're tired of listening to
that they want somebody to do some about
it and I have a ton of respect for this
this new committee that's been formed on
name image and likeness to look into it
was being chaired by Bao Ackerman the
the Commissioner the Big East but do I
think that that anything's going to
happen from that but is not forced to
happen no I don't I think if they looked
at it without sort of government
involvement in this and I think their
their result would have been boy it's
just too complicated so we're not going
to do anything but now it's it's a lot
less complicated and they'll find a
solution when when governing you know
the government is pushing the issue
that's that's an awfully big stick that
the government's holding right now well
last thing for you here is here in the
state of California perhaps the most
famous school certainly athletically and
most decorated school in that department
USC needs a new athletic director Lynn
Swann just retired not I wouldn't say
out of the blue we know I noticed your
your tweet about it Jay where you
pointed out the last three athletes
killed position players from the
football team what do you make of USC
needing a new ad yeah they've gone
quarterback running back in and wide
receiver with Mike Garrett Pat Haden and
endless lawn so maybe it's time they
gave offensive linemen or defensive
linemen a chance look this is all coming
from Carol folt who's the new president
at the University of Southern California
she came from the University of North
Carolina she's dealt with difficult
issues before and and USC needs an
overhaul so you know doing the same
thing over and over again is not going
to net them a different result right now
the the athletic department is not in
the best of shape so it's important that
they win and football and basketball
they've got a great resources and
they've got an unbelievable brand so I
think hiring the right person and it's
not a question of someone with with
business experience or someone who's
been in the athletic director realm it's
someone who you know someone who is the
right person for the job and there are a
lot of good candidates out there but but
I I'm a big admirer of Carol folt and I
think she'll make a good choice here Jay
appreciate the time always appreciate
chatting with you one of the highlights
of the summer was having you here in
person and giving you what you want
which was an Instagram photograph of me
and you on the shows Instagram page Jan
oh that's I have already blown it up
it's already blown up and it is in the
entryway as soon as you come in Levi's
bald head at your fault buzz right there
the famed Billis foyer that's what we
need that's what I wanted so I
appreciate you giving me what I want -
Jay thank you sir thank you you are the
man thanks for coming on Mnet's Jay
Bilas at Jay Bilas on twitter and at
real deal Jay Bilas on the ground for
more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR live or download the Rich Eisen
show app